David Boder: [In English] München, September the 20th, 1946, at Funkenkasernen, a camp for transient displaced people. I have here before me Mrs. Hildegarde Franz who is expecting to go to the United States.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Frau Franz, drehen Sie sich mal um und machen Sie sich’s bequem. Sie werden es warm haben, nehmen Sie den Mantel ab. Und in die Richtung sprechen, nicht wahr!
Hildegarde Franz: Ja.
David Boder: Also, Frau Franz, wollen Sie mir nochmal sagen, wie ist Ihr voller Name?
Hildegarde Franz: Hildegard Franz.
David Boder: Und wie alt sind Sie, darf man das wissen?
Hildegarde Franz: Fünf und siebzig Jahre.
David Boder: Nooooo.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja.
David Boder: Fünf und siebzig Jahre?
David Boder: Das ist doch nicht möglich. Sie sehen doch so jung aus
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, aber ich bin...
David Boder: Fünf und siebzig Jahre alt!
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja, ja, ha, hm, hm.
David Boder: Also. Nun Frau Franz, wollen Sie so gut sein und mir sagen, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg anfing?
Hildegarde Franz: Mein...
David Boder: Und dann so allmählich was hat Ihnen nach dem bis jetzt passiert?
Hildegarde Franz: Also ich war in Nürnberg, wir waren mit meinen Söhnen und meinem Mann, die waren beschäftigt bei meinen Angehörigen im Schloss Althen...
David Boder: Bei Ihren Angehörigen, ja?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja., bei Schloss Althen in Nürnberg—Konfektion...
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: . . . und im Jahre vier und dreißig mussten wir das Geschäft verkaufen, weil wir eben Juden waren, nicht...
David Boder: Schon so weit zurück in vier und dreißig?
Hildegarde Franz: . . . in vier und dreißig mussten wir...
David Boder: Also der Hitler wurde dann gewählt.
Hildegarde Franz: in drei und dreißig.
David Boder: Ja, also, wenn man denkt, er ist zur Kraft gekommen in drei und dreißig.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und in vier und dreißig müssen Sie...
Hildegarde Franz: . . . mussten wir unser Geschäft verkaufen—aus diesen Gründen, weil unser Personal nationalsozialistisch eingestellt war vollständig und hat jeden Kunden, der bei uns gekauft hat, das im Braunhaus gemeldet, so dass die Leute, die Kundschaft also, hm,...
David Boder: Aufgegeben haben...
Hildegarde Franz: . . . aufgegeben haben, Angst gehabt haben bei uns zu kaufen.
David Boder: Was für ein Geschäft war das?
Hildegarde Franz: Konfektion, Damenkonfektion, schon ganz große Damenkonfektion. Damenkonfektion.
David Boder: Haben Sie auch selber die, die, hm, Kleider fabriziert?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, nein, das nicht.
David Boder: Sie haben von Fabriken gekauft...
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, gekauft.
David Boder: Und dann fertig verkauft?
Hildegarde Franz: Verkauft, ja.
David Boder: Und das war in Heidelberg?
Hildegarde Franz: Das war in Nürnberg.
David Boder: In Nürnberg, entschuldigen Sie mal.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja.
David Boder: Das ist gerade jetzt dort, wo die Gerichtsverhandlung stattfindet, die, hm,
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: . . . für die Nazis.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja. Also...
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: . . . dann durfte mein Mann...ich habe in Mischehe gelebt, net wahr, da...
David Boder: Ihr Mann war Christ?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, mein Mann wurde mit meinen Söhnen—einfach weil ich Jüdin war—entlassen—auf der Strasse gesetzt so zu sagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Na ja, und dann haben wir eben, dann sind eben meine Söhne nach Amerika ausgewandert.
David Boder: Ach, im Jahre vier und dreißig hatten Ihre Söhne die Moeglichkleit nach Amerika auszuwandern?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Wer hat ihnen das Affidavit geschickt?
Hildegarde Franz: Mein Sohn hat einen Herren kennengelernt auf der, hm,...
David Boder: Ja, da sie haben keine Verwandten also...
Hildegarde Franz: Nein. Der hat meinem Sohn ein Besuchsvisum, mit ist er nach Amerika.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Und er ist dort ein Jahr geblieben und von da aus ist er, hat er...
David Boder: Nach?
Hildegarde Franz: . . . hat er seine Einreise für Amerika bekommen...
David Boder: Affidavit.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, bekommen und ist seit dem in Amerika in einem Geschäft,...seit zehn Jahren ist er in einem Geschäft
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Bei Kresge beschäftigt.
David Boder: Kresge?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, Kresge.
David Boder: Ist das nicht das Fünf und Zehn Geschäft?
Hildegarde Franz: Das ganz Grosse.
David Boder: Das ganz große Fünf und Zehn Geschäft.
Hildegarde Franz: Seit zehn Jahren ist er dort beschäftigt.
David Boder: Ja, ja. Das ist ein Sohn ist dort. Sie haben noch mehr in Amerika?
Hildegarde Franz: Ein Sohn ist in Colorado, also im Staat Colorado.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: In Durango und hat und ist auch seit sechs Jahren in einer Stellung.
David Boder: Aha. Sind sie dort verheiratet?
Hildegarde Franz: Mein einer Sohn ist verheiratet.
David Boder: Ja. Er hat seine Frau mitgenommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Doch, seine Frau ist dort.
David Boder: Er hat sie von hier mitgenommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, einer hat in Amerika geheiratet.
David Boder: Er hat in Amerika geheiratet.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, also mit wem sind Sie dann hier, Frau Franz?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich bin ganz alleine.
David Boder: Und was hat mit Ihrem Mann passiert?
Hildegarde Franz: Mein Mann ist gestorben.
David Boder: Wann?
Hildegarde Franz: Mein Mann war sehr, sehr leidend durch all die Unannehmlichkeiten und die Schwere, was auf uns gelegen hat. Dann ist mein Mann sehr, sehr leidend geworden, net wahr...
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: . . . und dann durch die Luftangriffe...
Hildegarde Franz: . . . die wir mitgemacht haben, war es nachher so...ich bin fast ein ganzes halbes Jahr nicht aus die Kleider gekommen, nur um meinem kranken Mann immer zu helfen, wenn die Luftangriffe kamen, dass ich ihn in den Keller bringen konnte. Da bin ich ein ganzes halbes Jahr nicht aus die Kleider.
David Boder: Wo waren Sie während dieser Zeit?
Hildegarde Franz: In Nürnberg.
David Boder: In Nürnberg.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, dann in 43 war ich...
David Boder: Ein Moment bitte. [Pause] Also weiter! Was hat dann in 43 passiert?
Hildegarde Franz: In 43 ist es dann...wie es so furchtbar war, bin ich mit meinem Mann für einige Wochen aufs Land. Da wurde er sehr, sehr krank und musste sich einer Operation, dann musste ich ihn wieder nach Nürnberg bringen, um ihn einer Operation zu unterziehen.
David Boder: Nun und ihr Mann war Christ?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja und...
David Boder: Er war Deutscher? Und...
Hildegarde Franz: Und er ist in Nürnberg dann gestorben.
David Boder: Wann ist er in Nürnberg gestorben...
Hildegarde Franz: In drei und...am 19. Oktober 43 starb mein Mann und am 17. Januar 44 hat man mich binnen 2 Tagen von meiner Wohnung raus...[weint]
David Boder: Was heißt das binnen 2 Tagen?
Hildegarde Franz: . . . musste ich meine Wohnung verlassen [weint und schluchzt] und bin ins KZ gekommen wo...wie schrecklich mit 73 Jahr [weint und schluchzt sehr]. [Pause] Ich muss mich erst ein bisschen fassen. [Pause] Mit 73 Jahren bin ich dann nach dem Tod meines Mannes nach zwei Monaten verschleppt worden nach Theresienstadt.
David Boder: Na, was haben die gesagt, warum das?
Hildegarde Franz: Gar nichts. Ich bin Jüdin.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Und weil ich Jüdin bin, bin ich einfach verschleppt worden.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mir, Sie sagen, sie haben Ihnen zwei Tage gegeben, Ihre Wohnung .zu liquidieren?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, und...ich konnte ja nicht die Wohnung räumen, ich musste ja alles stehen und liegen lassen. Und ich bin eben einfach...
David Boder: Bitte lauter.
Hildegarde Franz: Und ich bin eben einfach verschleppt worden...nach Theresienstadt.
David Boder: Also sagen Sie mal, wie viele Leute von Ihnen sind nach Theresienstadt gefahren?
Hildegarde Franz: Mit meinem Transport?
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Zehn...fünfzehn Personen es waren.
David Boder: Und wie hat man Sie nach Theresienstadt geschickt?
Hildegarde Franz: Man hat uns mit der Eisenbahn nach Theresienstadt...
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: geschickt und unter, hm, also Deckung also unter...von...ja, von SA, von der Gestapo.
David Boder: War das ein Passagier-Wagon?
Hildegarde Franz: Es war ein Last Wagon.
David Boder: Ein Last Wagon?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja.
David Boder: Und wer waren die anderen Leute mit Ihnen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das war ein Herr Kaufmann, hm, eine...ich weiß net...eine Frau Dessauer...er ist auch gestorben, Dessauer, Kaufmann, eine Frau Doktor Rodler...
David Boder: Ein bisschen lauter.
Hildegarde Franz: Eine Frau Dr. Rodler, eine, hm,...
David Boder: Na ja, ich meine, was für Leute waren da, die überhaupt so lange noch in Nürnberg geblieben sind?
Hildegarde Franz: Die waren alle, alle in Mischehen.
David Boder: Ah so, das waren Mischehen Leute.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja und die sind dann alle in 43, in 44 dann nach Theresienstadt verschleppt worden.
David Boder: Aber von diesen Mischehen, da hat man bloß die jüdische Hälfte genommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja nur die jüdische Hälfte...
David Boder: Die jüdische Hälfte von den, Mischehen.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und die sind dann nach Theresienstadt verschleppt worden.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, die jüdische Hälfte.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie mir, wie haben Sie Theresienstadt damals vorgefunden?
Hildegarde Franz: Na, wir haben Theresienstadt...wir haben...
David Boder: Es waren ja verschiedene Zeiten in Theresienstadt.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja.
David Boder: Also was für ein Platz wurde Ihnen angewiesen. Wie ist...
Hildegarde Franz: Uns wurde oben ein Boden angewiesen.
David Boder: Ein Boden von einem Hause?
Hildegarde Franz: Von einem Hause, wo wir wohnen...schlafen und wohnen mussten. Und...
David Boder: Und wer lebte unten?
Hildegarde Franz: Unten war ein Siechenheim, wo Kranke gelegen haben, oben auf den Boden sind wir gekommen.
David Boder: Was für ein Heim?
Hildegarde Franz: Ein Siechenheim, wo nur Kranke waren.
David Boder: Warum hat das Siechenheim geheißen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das ist halt so genannt, ich weiß es nicht.
David Boder: Wie buchstabieren Sie das?
Hildegarde Franz: [Sie buchstabiert] S...S-i-e-c-h...
David Boder: S?
Hildegarde Franz: Siechen. [Sie buchstabiert] S-I-e-c-h-e-n-Heim, Siechenheim.
David Boder: Ja. Und Sie haben dann auf dem Boden ober diesem Siechenheim gewohnt.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, oben.
David Boder: Also wie viele Leute waren in einem Zimmer?
Hildegarde Franz: Also in dem Boden waren ungefähr 35 Menschen untergebracht.
David Boder: Frauen allein?
Hildegarde Franz: Nur...Frauen und Männer...alles durcheinand.
David Boder: Im selben Zimmer?
Hildegarde Franz: Alles im selben Zimmer
David Boder: Und wir haben Sie dort geschlafen?
Hildegarde Franz: Na ja, wir haben geschlafen so in einem Kasten mit einem Strohsack.
David Boder: Aha, für jeden Einen, ein Bett für jeden so zu sagen.
Hildegarde Franz: Ein Bett, ja.
David Boder: Mit einem Strohsack.
Hildegarde Franz: Mit einem Strohsack, ja. ?
David Boder: Nun was für sagen haben Sie für sich mitgenommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Eine Kleinig...Ich durfte nur mitnehmen ein...also, das Notwendigste. Einen Koffer mit Kleider, also was ich gerade gebraucht hab und etwas Wäsche, eine Decke und ein Kissen.
David Boder: Aha! Und das hat man Ihnen in Theresienstadt gelassen?
Hildegarde Franz: Mir hat man es gelassen, aber Vielen...da hab ich Glück gehabt, aber Vielen ist es auch noch gestohlen worden, dass sie gar nichts gehabt haben. Viele...
David Boder: Und nun? Haben Sie..., hm, wie war es dann nachher in Theresienstadt?
Hildegarde Franz: Na ja...
David Boder: Wie lange waren Sie dort? Und...
Hildegarde Franz: Ein einhalb Jahr—bis die Befreiung durch die Russen kam.
David Boder: Waren Sie gesund?
Hildegarde Franz: Sieben Wochen hab ich im Krankenhaus gelegen.
David Boder: Im selben Siechenheim?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, nein. In einem Krankenhaus, also das ‚Grand Hotel’ hat es geheißen.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Und da war ich sieben Wochen gelegen, weil ich so schnell abgemagert bin.
David Boder: Hm.
Hildegarde Franz: In der Zeit von drei Monaten, vier Monate habe ich vierzig Pfund abgenommen. Das war zu viel. Da haben die ganzen inneren Organe, Herz und alles, darunter gelitten, net wahr.
Hildegarde Franz: Da war ich also sieben Wochen im Krankenhaus.
David Boder: Und was hat man dort für Sie getan?
Hildegarde Franz: Was kann man auch? [wimmert] Ach Du lieber Gott, was konnten sie schon viel tun? Ich hab eben im Krankenaus gelegen und bin behandelt worden, net wahr, und bin eigentlich zu früh entlassen worden, weil das Krankenhaus für nur Lungenkranke gebraucht worden ist.
David Boder: Ahm.
Hildegarde Franz: Und dann bin ich wieder auf meinen Boden zurückgekommen.
David Boder: Wer waren die Ärzte im Krankenhaus?
Hildegarde Franz: Das war ein Dr. Gutmann.
David Boder: . Waren die jüdische Ärzte?
Hildegarde Franz: Das waren jüdische Ärzte, es waren ja nur Juden dort.
David Boder: Ja, ich verstehe. Und die Ärzte waren jüdisch, nicht wahr?
Hildegarde Franz: Die waren jüdisch, ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, wie die Zeit voran ging und es nahe zur Niederlage kam, haben sich die Dinge zum Besseren in Theresienstadt geändert?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, also ich mein, wir haben sie jetzt gar net mehr daran geglaubt, dass wir überhaupt, wie soll ich sagen—befreit werden, weil wir vollständig von der Welt abgeschlossen waren. Wir haben ja keine Nachrichten und nichts bekommen.
David Boder: Keine Zeitungen und keine Magazine?
Hildegarde Franz: Gar nichts. Nichts. Keine Zeitung, kein Radio, ein offener Brief, der in einem Paketchen gelegen hat, der ist auch weggenommen worden.
David Boder: Haben Sie irgendwelche Pakete bekommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich nicht, nicht ein Paketchen.
David Boder: Warum?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich habe nichts bekommen, [wimmert oder weint] niemand hat mir was geschickt.
David Boder: Hatten sie irgendwelche Freunde in Heidelberg...
Hildegarde Franz: In Nürnberg.
David Boder: In Nürnberg, irgendwelche Bekannte, die dort geblieben sind?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, aber ich war...die haben mir alle nichts geschickt. Ich habe auch nichts verlangt, weil ich die Leute nicht in Ungelegenheit bringen wollte, net wahr, denn es war ja auch streng verboten, dass die Juden irgend etwas geschickt bekommen sollen.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, haben Sie noch etwas Geld gehabt?
Hildegarde Franz: In Theresienstadt—nein, keinen Pfennig.
David Boder: Wieso?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich hab kein Geld mitnehmen dürfen.
David Boder: Oh, haben Sie welches Geld in...
Hildegarde Franz: Aber in Theresienstadt da war—schade, ich habe keines dabei—da hat man ein Ghetto Geld gehabt, net wahr.
David Boder: Ja. Und wer hat das bekommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das haben wir bekommen, da konnte man...
David Boder: Wofür?
Hildegarde Franz: . . . dass man irgend etwas kaufen konnte.
David Boder: Ja, aber Sie haben das Geld umsonst bekommen? Oder...
Hildegarde Franz: Das haben wir jeden Monat bekommen—50 Kronen, net wahr...
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Ghetto Geld.
David Boder: Ja, mit diesem Mooses Bild drauf.
Hildegarde Franz: Mooses Bild drauf, ja, ja. Da hab ich einen Satz davon mir aufgehoben.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, und da mussten wir den Juden Stern alle tragen, net.
Hildegarde Franz: Und man hat uns...also...die Ernährung war mehr wie wenig.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie ernährt? Haben Sie in Ihrem Hause dort gekocht oder...?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, wir waren von einer Küche gespeist.
David Boder: Und wer hat das Essen abgeholt?
Hildegarde Franz: Das mussten wir uns alle holen. Da haben wir uns anstellen müssen und uns das Essen holen.
David Boder: Standen Sie in einem [unverständlich]?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, es waren Strassen, net wahr.
David Boder: Und da haben Sie sich das Essen geholt und wo haben Sie gegessen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das hat man sich gewöhnlich mit heimgenommen und ich hab mich auf mein Bett hingesetzt und ich hab es gegessen. Einen Tisch haben wir ja net gekannt, einen Tisch hat es ja in unserem Zimmer net gegeben. Und man musste sich immer auf sein Bett hinsetzen.
David Boder: Nun—und haben Sie Ihre Bettwäsche behalten?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ich hab also meine eigenen Bettwäsche gehabt, die hatte ich mit genommen und die hab ich mir dann immer gewaschen.
David Boder: Aha. Haben Sie genug Seife gehabt?
Hildegarde Franz: Seife—eigentlich, wie sagt man—das war eine Schmierseife, die wir bekommen haben.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Aber das war auch sehr wenig, nicht.
David Boder: Ja und dann, ist es gegen das Ende ein bisschen besser geworden?
Hildegarde Franz: Oh, ja also, da sind ab und zu Kommissionen gekommen.
David Boder: Ja. .
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, so von Schweden und der Schweiz.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja und dann musste es uns ein bisschen besser...
David Boder: Hm.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja und dann ist dann alles also was sie zeigen wollen und die Nazi haben gezeigt, dass sie alles in Ordnung gebracht haben und das Andere ist geblieben, wie es war. Dann haben wir wohl ein bisschen Essen mehr bekommen und wenn sie weg waren, die Kommissionen, dann haben sie es wieder abgezogen. Dann haben wir schon wieder weniger bekommen, nicht.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie, wer waren die Nazis mit denen Sie in Kontakt kamen?
Hildegarde Franz: Wir kamen eigentlich mit den Nazis weniger in Kontakt. Das war der Ältestenrat, der hat die Befehle von den Nazis bekommen und der Ältestenrat musste dann das ausführen.
David Boder: Erinnern Sie sich an die Leute vom Ältestenrat?
Hildegarde Franz: Vom Ältestenrat...ich hab eigentlich...warten Sie mal...ein...einen—wie hat der geheißen? Einen Herrn Meier kennengelernt. Ansonsten niemanden.
David Boder: Niemand, hm.
Hildegarde Franz: Weil ich einmal vorgeladen war zur Kommandantur, wo man mir ein Testament, was ich mit meinem Mann verfasst hatte im Jahre 32. Und da hat man mir gesagt auf der Kommandantur, ob mein Mann das handschriftlich geschrieben hätte, das Testament. Und man wollte, ich sollte es umstoßen.
David Boder: Warum umstoßen?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab mich damit nicht verstanden. Ich hab nur gesagt, ich hab mit meinem Mann in einer sehr glücklichen Ehe gelebt, einer drei und vierzig [43] jährigen, sehr glücklichen Ehe. Und meinem Mann sein Wille war mir heilig, das hab ich ihnen auch erklärt. Das...
David Boder: War das eine jüdische Gruppe, die Ihnen das gesagt...
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, das waren die...
David Boder: Die SS...
Hildegarde Franz: Die SS. Das war die Gestapo, die mich da...nicht die SS...
David Boder: Ja, was war denn dort in dem Testament, das denen nicht gefallen hat?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, jedenfalls, dass ich alles, also von da war alles auf den Namen meines Mannes, net.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Und wenn ich eben das jedenfalls umgestoßen hätte, dann hätten sie eben alles bewohnt, net, und so...
Hildegarde Franz: Und so war es...
David Boder: Also was war denn da zu bewohnen?
Hildegarde Franz: Also mein Mann...wir haben da ja etwas Grund gehabt, net wahr, und die Wohnung...
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: . . . und dass die Möbel und was alles da war. Und da waren sie doch sehr scharf drauf, um das wieder weiter auf ihre Nazi zu verteilen und deshalb war es ihnen auch sehr darum zu tun und das konnten sie eben nicht, weil alles auf den Namen meines Mannes gegangen ist, net. . .
Hildegarde Franz: Und ich hab mich nicht einverstanden, es frei zu geben.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Net wahr!
David Boder: Haben sie Ihnen nicht gedroht?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, ich hab nur gesagt zu ihnen, ich würde mich unter keinen Umständen dazu verstehen, dass ich den Willen meines Mannes zuwiderhandeln kann und ich...es muss so bleiben, wie es ist und es jetzt ist.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie dann, Frau Franz, hm, wie kam die Befreiung?
Hildegarde Franz: Die Befreiung kam durch die Russen.
David Boder: Hm, wie sind die herein gekommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das war am achten, neunten Mai; am achten, neunten Mai kamen die.
David Boder: 45?
Hildegarde Franz: 45.
David Boder: Und was hat dann passiert?
Hildegarde Franz: Dann gingen die fluchtartig weg, die noch da waren, net wahr—die sind abgerückt natürlich und haben alles in einem Durcheinander liegen gelassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Hildegarde Franz: Und die Russen haben uns anständig behandelt.
David Boder: Hm.
Hildegarde Franz: Wir haben Essen bekommen mehr und sind auch richtig verpflegt worden.
David Boder: So—und wann sind Sie nach Nürnberg zurück gekommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Na, wir sind zurück gekommen am 2. Juli 45; sind wir - von den Amerikanern in, in Theresienstadt abgeholt.
David Boder: In Camion, Autobussen?
Hildegarde Franz: In Autobussen—in so Lastwagen sind wir abgeholt worden.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie in Nürnberg vorgefunden von Ihrem Eigentum?
Hildegarde Franz: Nichts mehr. [Pause] Das Haus ist ausgebombt...
David Boder: War es Ihr eigenes Haus?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, es war nicht mein eigenes Haus. Ich hab—nein, von meiner ganzen Wohnung habe ich fast nichts mehr gerettet. Die Leute, die bei mir in Untermiete gewohnt haben, die haben sich ziemlich gütlich daran getan.
David Boder: Haben Sie welche Kleidung gefunden, haben Sie...
Hildegarde Franz: Gar nichts! Ich hatte nur einige Sachen, die hatte ich verlagert, was ein paar Wertsachen waren, beim einem Dr. Mombert...
David Boder: Einem Christen?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja. Er hat mir das blendend aufgehoben, während in meiner Wohnung eine Mischehe gewohnt hat, die gerade das Gegenteil waren. Ich aber die Leute nicht...
David Boder: Na ja, Sie wollen sich nicht beklagen...
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, ich will ihnen nichts anhaben, sie haben mich um Vieles gebracht...
David Boder: Das war eine Mischehe, die dort gelebt haben?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und denen hat nichts passiert während...
Hildegarde Franz: Die sind, hm, dann von der Wohnung weg, also es ist...eine Bombe gestürzt, net wahr...
David Boder: Hm und dann?
Hildegarde Franz: . . . und die hat eine Wand abgerissen, aber die sagen, die Möbel sind dort stehen geblieben, net...
David Boder: Ah hm.
Hildegarde Franz: . . . zumindestens ein großer Teil. Und wo die hingekommen sind—ich hab wohl Einiges zurück bekommen, aber größtenteils sagen sie...haben sie gesagt, sie haben nichts mehr.
David Boder: Und von Ihrem Bankkonto? Haben Sie das zurück bekommen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das habe ich zurück bekommen.
David Boder: Das haben Ihnen die Amerikaner zurück gegeben?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Und sie erlauben es Ihnen, es raus zu nehmen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das hat man eigentlich auch bekommen.
David Boder: Ja, also das war dann sicher?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, das war sicher. Aber meine Wohnungseinrichtung...da habe ich sehr, sehr viel verloren.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mal, hatten Sie dann schnell Kontakt mit Ihren...mit Ihren Söhnen, hm? [lacht etwas]
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ich hab es durch einen Amerikaner bekommen—Kontakt mit...mit...
David Boder: Haben Sie telegraphiert oder so?
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, mein Sohn hat mir erst eine Depesche geschickt, weil ich einen Brief ihm geschrieben hab. Dann bekam ich eine, hm, eine Depesche, wo er sich kolossal gefreut hat, dass ich noch am Leben bin.
David Boder: Hm.
Hildegarde Franz: Die haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich noch lebe.
David Boder: Also wann denken Sie, dass Sie fahren?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich fahr jetzt am vier und zwanzigsten...
David Boder: Welchen vier und zwanzigsten?
Hildegarde Franz: . . . vier und zwanzigsten September mit dem Transport.
David Boder: Wohin?
Hildegarde Franz: Nach Bremen.
David Boder: Oh, und dann geht das Schiff von Bremen?
Hildegarde Franz: Das Schiff geht von Bremen, ja!
David Boder: Oh, ja, denn ich dachte, dass Sie vielleicht nach Paris fahren, denn ich fahre am neun und zwanzigsten.
Hildegarde Franz: Nein, nein.
David Boder: Auf der Washington?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Da fahren Sie auf einem militärischen Schiff?
Hildegarde Franz: Ja, ja, ahm.
David Boder: Nun das ist eigentlich ein gutes Ende zu einem bösen Spiel.
Hildegarde Franz: Ja. Ich habe viel, viel gelitten!
David Boder: Ja, das...das weiß man schon. Das...
Hildegarde Franz: Ich hab furchtbar gelitten [weint] ich darf gar nicht daran denken, [Pause]...wie schwer ich es gehabt hab.
David Boder: Wohin gehen Sie? Nach Newark?
Hildegarde Franz: Zu meinem Sohn.
David Boder: Ja, nach Newark. Und der Andere—sagen Sie—ist in...
Hildegarde Franz: Ist in Durango, Colorado, im Staate Colorado.
David Boder: Ja, es wird Ihnen auch dort gefallen, es ist warm und schön...
Hildegarde Franz: Die Kinder freuen sich natürlich, [weint]...dass sie eine Mutter noch haben.
David Boder: Na ja, die sollen sich auch freuen!
Hildegarde Franz: Es ist furchtbar gewesen, ich kann Ihnen das gar nicht erklären, [flüstert] wie schrecklich das alles war.
David Boder: Hm.
Hildegarde Franz: Ich bin...mit siebzig Pfund bin ich zurück gekommen
David Boder: Wieviel haben Sie gewogen?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich habe fünfzig Pfund zu...
David Boder: Wieviel wiegen Sie jetzt?
Hildegarde Franz: Jetzt werde ich ungefähr mein altes Gewicht haben.
David Boder: Wieviel?
Hildegarde Franz: Zwischen einhundert fünfzehn und einhundert zwanzig Pfund, aber wie ich von Theresienstadt zurück gekommen bin, habe ich nur 70 Pfund gewogen.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mal, waren in Theresienstadt welche Selektionen, dass man Leute weg geschickt hat von dort?
Hildegarde Franz: Hm, ja, Transporte meinen Sie?
David Boder: Ja, von Theresienstadt.
Hildegarde Franz: Ohhhhh, Gott im Himmel!
David Boder: Erzählen Sie uns davon.
Hildegarde Franz: Also, in meinem, wie ich...da hat man viele, viele Menschen nach Polen geschickt.
David Boder: Aus welchem Grund, wie hat man die gewählt?
Hildegarde Franz: Einfach, die sind einfach...die Transportabteilung, da sind viele Menschen, die sind mit dem Transport alle nach Polen gegangen—teils nach Auschwitz, teils nach Belsen-Bergen. Nach, nach, na, [unverständlich; murmelt]...na, wie die ganzen KZ Lager da geheißen haben und diese Menschen sind größtenteils alle umgekommen. Dann ist ein Transport—das war der Letzte—im Oktober, da sind achtzehn tausend Menschen von Theresienstadt verschleppt worden.
David Boder: Achtzehn tausend?
Hildegarde Franz: Achtzehn tausend Menschen sind von Theresienstadt verschleppt worden nach Polen.
David Boder: Wie haben sie diese gewählt? Sind welche Reichsdeutsche darunter—unter Denen gewesen?
Hildegarde Franz: Deutsche...und alle mögliche...alle möglichen Nationen.
David Boder: Und wie ist es Ihnen gelungen dort zu bleiben?
Hildegarde Franz: Wo? Ich?
David Boder: In Theresienstadt, ja.
Hildegarde Franz: In Theresienstadt. Das weiß ich nicht—ich bin halt nicht darunter gewesen.
David Boder: Was?
Hildegarde Franz: Ich war halt nicht drunter. Ich bin nicht dazu gekommen...
David Boder: Sie haben Glück gehabt!
Hildegarde Franz: Ich hab Glück gehabt!
David Boder: Welche von ihren Transporten von...die mit Ihnen, die von Nürnberg weg gegangen sind?
Hildegarde Franz: Wurden mit nach Polen geschickt, ja, nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Aha.
Hildegarde Franz: Und von diesen ist eine Einzige zurück gekommen. Es war noch ein jüngerer Mensch, die Anderen sind alle umgekommen.
David Boder: [In English] There is a correction: four people from her transport were sent to Poland, and one returned of these four, a younger person.
David Boder: This concludes the interview with Miss Hildegarde— [correction] with Mrs. Hildegarde Franz, age seventy-five, born in Nuremberg, or who lived in Nuremberg in a mixed marriage with a Christian husband, and who after his death was sent to Theresienstadt. She is now in the UNRRA camp at Funkenkasernen in Munich. And the 24th of this month—that means in four days—Bremen, and from Bremen sailing to the United States to her son in Newark, and to the other one in Colorado. This concludes the interview with Miss [Mrs.] Hildegarde Franz at twenty minutes of the spool. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.